Twitter's former head of security is
telling Congress the social media
platform has put its users at risk Peter
zotko a former hacker better known to
many as much testified at a senate
hearing which revealed FBI allegations
that at least one spy from China worked
for Twitter as Scott McFarland shows us
zatko who was fired by Twitter back in
January did not hold back
when an influential media platform can
be compromised by teenagers thieves and
spies this is a big deal for all of us
Twitter's former head of security turned
whistleblower told lawmakers on the
Senate Judiciary Committee the platform
is extremely vulnerable to exploitation
would you agree with me that Twitter has
put its users health and safety severely
at risk
yes sir and it's put the National
Security severely at risk yes sir Peter
zotko claims Twitter which has more than
237 million daily users has failed to
ensure privacy for its accounts and
hasn't done enough to safeguard the
company against potential Bad actors in
its Workforce you're telling me they
cannot even identify foreign agents in
their midst uh yes ma'am they're not
even attempting to a Twitter
spokesperson disputed claims of foreign
influence and said data access is
predicated on security measures like
background checks they also told CBS
news that goes allegations are quote
riddled with inconsistencies and
inaccuracies but zatgo testified a rogue
employee could take control of or even
sell access to profiles including
verified accounts like the Senators I've
seen numerous accounts on underground
forums offering to sell such access
whether those are valid or not but I've
seen the offers to sell access two
accounts to delete accounts to unban
accounts the Senate hearing could open
the door to sweeping new federal rules
and regulations for platforms from
Twitter to Facebook to tick tock when it
comes to this area of the law technology
privacy security and the law Congress
needs to play catch-up
this all comes as Twitter shareholders
voted Monday to approve a bid by Elon
Musk to buy the company musk has tried
to back out of that 44 billion dollar
deal setting the stage for a big legal
battle next month Nate
Scott thank you